this video is sponsored by raycon
as you guys know i'm doing these reviews
completely blind
and so all i see when i look at my
bookshelf is a clear delineation between
two colors white and black these
obviously represent two separate parts
of naruto and because i only had one arc
left in the white section i was
interested to see just how kishimoto
would end this part of the story and i'm
gonna be honest i also looked at this
last arc and instead of seeing just the
story i saw eight full volumes for me to
finish reading before i could begin
writing this video however once i
finished this arc i noticed something
something i had harshly criticized this
story for not having has now become one
of its strongest attributes today i want
to share with you all my first
impressions and review for the final arc
of original naruto
and what an arc it is
[Music]
remember when i said that i looked on
with concern at the eight full volumes
of manga i had to read and review this
week well what an idiot i was the
material in these volumes are easily
some of the most simple in terms of
story but also have i think the very
best paneling and layout work from
kishimoto that i've seen yet making the
entire process of reading deceptively
quick and seamless i'm telling you i was
slamming volumes like pints at christmas
often when it comes to the artists
behind these famous mangas the
development or change of their
respective artistic approaches styles
occurs unconsciously and gradually over
time jojo dragon ball and one piece are
clear and striking examples of this
phenomenon comparing their work from the
beginning of their run to their most
recent stuff highlights my point natural
changes occur and while some of this can
explain part of what's happened to
kishimoto's work here as a mangaka i
think there's also a very conscious
effort being exerted here in the
beginning of volume 20 kishimoto invents
his frustrations with the manga format
drawing from top right to bottom left
calling it limiting and this frustration
can be felt in the volumes concerning
this section specifically sporting
gorgeous pages and panels that really
grab my attention the likes of which i
haven't seen much from kishimoto at all
it's wonderful to see a mangaka 200
chapters into his career still trying to
push himself to innovate but what's
interesting about this change compared
to the aforementioned mangaka is that
kishimoto's transition is directly
influenced by the very thing that's
trying to mimic him that's right
kishimoto was directly influenced by
naruto's anime's character designer
tetsuya nishio he saw some amazing
design work coming from nishio on the
anime and loved how it seemed like such
a great mix of cenon and shannon styles
he thought it was the ideal art style
he'd been looking for and ever since
he'd been mimicking nishio's drawings in
a lot of these author notes sections
kishimoto brings up many famous
animators such as hiroyuki okira who
worked on super famous scenes on things
like ghost in the shell and acura which
makes me think he's a bit of an
animation nut i mentioned one particular
animator who has largely defined what
naruto action is and that's norio
matsumoto sasuke vs orochimaru rockley
versus gara orochimaru versus the third
hokage and now naruto vs sasuke all
these iconic scenes come from this man
and as i've watched those and continued
to read i've noticed kishimoto's work
beginning to resemble the energy and
posing found in matsumoto's work i can
only theorize about his influence here
but given kishimoto's love of animation
it seems like a safe bet having already
achieved so much notoriety in the
industry with so many people at this
point looking up to him i think it's a
great sign of a mangaka and a person to
be able to look outward and inward for a
means to try and improve himself it
really does seem like the more i learn
about kishimoto as a person the more i
realize how close he is to naruto as a
character
[Music]
while the conclusions to the prior arcs
activity with the assault in the village
after being dealt with and the selection
of the latest hokage after being
finalized i was fully expecting this arc
to feel like a footnote after everything
that's happened
[Music]
i was wrong despite being one of the
longest arcs among the material i've
covered so far the story in question is
remarkably simple which meant that a lot
of space was given to this arc's various
components to breathe build up and
climax appropriately and boy do they
climax appropriately the first act of
this arc is the one that carries most of
the heavy lifting from an expository and
foundational sense upon which the rest
of the arc launches from comfortably
that said the rest of this arc consists
of a series of fights and chase scenes
and that might not sound interesting but
kishimoto makes it work really well
act one if i could describe this arc in
one word it would be cathartic and
focused having come off the back of a
rip-roaring couple of arcs with more
conflict than you could swing a cat at
going into this i was curious to see the
direction kishimoto was going to take
sure we'd have to deal with the
aftermath of the attack on the village
and lady tsunade is settling into her
new position but outside of that i
didn't see much else to deal with
outside of perhaps the itachi and sasuke
conflict in the last arc while i didn't
speak much about it itachi very much
cemented himself as one of the most
terrifying major players in the story as
soon as he appeared on the other side of
the door facing naruto i sincerely felt
the tension and pressure rise which is
exactly the sort of impression you want
from a major villain or antagonist and
the action and drama that took fuel from
that encounter as sasuke entered the
fray to make the save on naruto it felt
like a monumental moment in every sense
of the word that was building to
something however then the rug is pulled
from beneath us despite the other arcs
that make up the rest of this first part
of naruto being somewhat more complex
with a greater number of moving parts
this arc and its eight volumes primarily
concern themselves with sasuke's
relationship with his brother and the
choices he makes in seeking revenge in
response to that and i loved it my
biggest complaint after i finished the
very first arc of naruto was that it
felt somewhat unfocused and now in this
arc not only are things incredibly
simple but each facet of this arc now
receives ample attention
sasuke vs naruto round one funnily
enough despite being mentioned once
before that sasuke desired to test
himself against naruto this matchup for
one reason or another faded into the
back of my subconscious as something i
either didn't know i wanted or one that
i totally forgot about and i have no
idea why because on paper these two
squaring off makes complete sense and
are a terrific matchup narratively
speaking i mentioned before in an
earlier video that i felt the closer
naruto came to achieving his goal the
farther away sasuke would be pushed by
his with orochimaru having laid that
metaphorical chekhov's gun before us
when he said sasuke needs to seek out
more power by embracing the darkness in
his heart i knew a scene or sequence of
events would play out like this and it's
so much better than i thought it would
be made possible thanks to some key
pieces of symbolism laid out across this
series the initial fight that kicks off
this arc's activity is short but
punctuated powerfully by a striking
visual by really putting into
perspective the gap that's appearing
between himself and naruto however at
this point in the story i think it's
important to point out that their
relationship isn't necessarily
interesting to me because of their
dynamic on its own and that largely has
to do with kakashi and jiraiya pretty
much telling us explicitly what's
happening narratively between them we're
not left to understand this on our own
by reading the material and
understanding it ourselves and as a
result this exposition feels clunky and
did take away from this short but
opening fight between them then again
this is a manga for young teens so i'm
gonna let it slide i will however say
what i did really enjoy was the role
mentors are playing in this story
whether that be kakashi and sasuke which
i will definitely speak about more later
jiraiya's relationship with naruto as
i've described in the past sakura's new
budding relationship with lady tsunade
and of course guy's relationship with
rock lee rockley's been an interesting
character in this story from the moment
i met him back during the tuning exams i
knew i liked this little guy with him
time and time again throughout the story
whether it be in the force of death the
fight with gara or his rehabilitation
after that fight he sort of in a way
stood as an example of what a hero with
a similar mentality to that of naruto
might appear like if he didn't have an
all-powerful spirit trapped within him
when naruto in the first half of this
story contended with inadequacy and a
chip on his shoulder eventually
kishimoto was forced to transition his
character from one that struggled to
make a difference to one who had to deal
with the high expectations from those
around him lee on the other hand because
of the lack of advantages he has
compared to naruto can fully lean into
and embrace angles and outcast character
like naruto once was afforded naruto can
self-heal thanks to the fox spirit
inside him and so a natural way to
explore lee's character to further
distinguish him from naruto is to have
him absorb a tremendous amount of damage
and the consequences of that action
which brings me to his mentor guy in
many ways the mentor characters in this
story mirror key attributes of their
students personalities gai is perhaps
the most pronounced variation on this
concept everything from his appearance
to his desire to prove himself against
kakashi to his soul-destroying training
exercises in every sense of the word the
connection between guy and lee is as
powerful as it is because they feel like
father and son once again providing lee
in the story horrific odds for anyone to
have to face let alone a young teenager
i spoke about guy before in a prior part
saying that i thought he saw a
tremendous amount of himself in lee and
due to that sees him as something of an
inspiration to even him and while that
was true in this arc their relationship
is tested as guy comes face to face with
the consequences of the path he laid
this young boy down and so he's faced
with a dilemma does he encourage him
like he always had to look the odds in
the eye on blinking and take the surgery
which has a 50 mortality rate or does he
choose to discourage him out of sympathy
for his situation it's a tremendous
amount of responsibility and it's a
fascinating character study within this
arc that i think has the most emotional
resonance
if you're in the market for new wireless
earbuds that offer the same quality as
premium brand at half the price then
raycon's everyday earbuds are exactly
what you need they've got a super slick
rubber oil look and feel that at least
to me look pretty damn great and match
their premium sound with a whole bunch
of gel tips available they've always got
a perfect in-ear fit too i've been using
mine for several months now and they've
quickly become the best earbuds i've
ever owned whether i'm just out and
about walking my dogs or sat at home
writing videos like these they've got me
covered with a built-in mic i can take
calls at the press of a button and even
leave voice memos for myself the fact
that's got 8 hours of constant play time
and a 32-hour battery life means they're
always ready to go whenever i need them
if you're interested click the link in
the description box or go to buy raycon
dot com forward slash not mark to unlock
exclusive deals up to 20 off your recon
order with a 45 day happiness guarantee
if you don't love him you can send him
right back
[Music]
act two the scene where sasuke chooses
to leave to connect with the dark side
is actually a lot more effective than i
thought it would be it's certainly not
profound or anything like that but it
really does feel authentic and honest to
the characters involved which is the
most important thing in this scene
sakura tries her best to persuade sasuke
to stay with them and in doing so pours
her heart out in a tender albeit awkward
scene which i honestly thought was
appropriate and well perfect they are
just kids after all struggling to
navigate the minefield that is
expressing how they feel about each
other while under extreme stress with
little practice in that area and it
absolutely came across that way i really
did feel sorry for sakura during this
part and while i don't vibe too much
with her as a character i did think this
felt very authentic and appropriate for
her and following sasuke leaving the
foundation is now set for the chase that
will follow that day with none other
than shikamaru now a tuning being tasked
with assembling a team interestingly
while naruto was the obvious choice and
is chosen to be part of the team negi
kiba and choji were less expected by me
but absolutely welcomed in my mind the
chase that eventually gets underway i
thought was brilliant while there was a
little bit of a slow burn towards the
middle i definitely thought the
attention given to the fights really
helped the pacing as well as elevate the
various characters that otherwise didn't
get the attention they deserved earlier
in this story shikamaru while having
been given some shine in prior arcs now
leads the group of young ninja with an
impressive and strategic fashion that
absolutely highlighted not only his
upside as a leader and strategist but
when things didn't go 100 to plan with
his group's numbers dwindling it also
led him to question himself wondering if
he was good enough which for such a
certain and calculated character really
helped to humanize him in a way i wasn't
expecting grounding him while also
exhibiting his greatest strengths and
techniques and really that's what this
middle section does exceptionally well
it helps to re-establish these
lesser-known and seldom focused on
characters offers them the chance to
show their absolute best and shows their
internal struggles and doubts the way
this chase is organized it acts as a
sort of conga line for lack of a better
term of orochimaru's goons to get
through and so one after another part of
shikimaru's team has to drop off to
fight each member of this group as they
continue to carry sasuke off in a basket
for orochimaru to take the body of
choji's fight is first and honestly when
i look at neji's and kibas alongside
this i thought this one did it best the
rest follow a very similar format to
this and so on top of it benefiting from
being the first time we see this sort of
sequence and format i think there's a
lot more we can dig into with this
material seeing as negi for example
already had an emotionally charged fight
with naruto during the tuning exams that
dealt with much of the same subject
matter discussed in this fight
specifically furthermore choji has this
so i guess kishimoto took a leaf out of
one piece's playbook and gave choji
rumble balls and man does he get massive
during this honestly i didn't know what
to expect with this but once again
similar to what made shikamaru effective
during this section the conflict choji
endures serves as a great vehicle to
demonstrate his skills that make him
unique but it also highlights his
insecurities and shortcomings as a ninja
and a human being too i think out of all
the fights in this section choji's was
by far my favorite and while i was
reading through this material too i was
shocked by how fast i was flying through
it the fights in this section felt both
compelling and brief with the likes of
choji and neji receiving plenty of
wonderful two-page spreads while also
demonstrating these sound ninja's second
forms acting as a foreshadowing of
things to come for sasuke i thought the
second form design is a sound ninja's
brandish war phenomenal i wasn't so sure
about them each getting a new
transformation at first though i thought
the effect would get lessened each and
every time with it being more and more
formulaic but in actuality because the
designs were so great i actually ended
up getting hyped for what they would
eventually look like when they did
change furthermore once naruto and
shikamaru's respective fights get
underway then the tempo really starts to
ramp up particularly when it comes to
naruto's fight with this strange new
character coming to take the basket
housing sasuke away naruto assumes that
feral mode he slips into when his
friends are in danger and the artwork
accompanying it is appropriately awesome
however things as they often do during
stories go to [ __ ]
and when they did hear
something amazing happened
[Music]
lee [ __ ] arrives to make the same i'm
not sure if my energy in this recording
will accurately show just how excited i
felt when he showed up but i went
bananas because honestly i loved this
little character i spoke about how the
last few volumes and fights really felt
somewhat formulaic in that they
effectively achieved the same sort of
things narratively but that formula has
been thrown right out the window and
replaced with the pure chaos lee has
injected into this fight however as
things want to go in this story we can't
have too much of a good thing for too
long but that doesn't mean what we
receive as a replacement isn't great
also
at the beginning of volume 24 kishimoto
reminisced about his experience reading
dragon ball vol 24 for the first time
and how that was where goku fought
against ginyu he described the affair as
something he was massively excited to
read through and hope that he could make
naruto more exciting when i opened that
volume after reading nothing but what
felt like quite safe choices up until
now this volume exploded with interest
near impossible to predict match-ups and
last-minute saves light the fight with
lee and his drunken monkey technique
which was hilarious and surprisingly
effective against the worsening odds
right after his surgery and then gara
and the other sand ninja show up i'm not
even remotely kidding here it's felt
like more has happened in the last five
chapters than there has been in the last
four volumes it's honestly brilliant
stuff kimi maro is a brilliant looking
villain at his fight against lee and
eventually gara is brilliantly handled
he is one of the most unsettling and
awesome looking ninjas i've come across
in this story and when he whipped out
his spine and used it as a sword i was
like okay look i know i'm not a big fan
of action only moments but that was
really freaking cool this fight is
honestly not one i would ever have
thought to create if left my own devices
but the two powers on display here sand
manipulation and bone manipulation
created perhaps the most visually
stunning battle sequence i've seen from
this manga to date defensively
offensively and the strategy employed by
both warriors was enough to win my heart
a million times over and throwing lee
into the mix only served to exacerbate
that feeling for me watching these two
one-time enemies work together and in a
sense save each other was immensely
satisfying and we're not done yet there
are moments in pop culture where you
have to sit back and recognize that this
was a moment not only pivotal to the
story that it takes part in but one that
has influenced and impacted the lives of
millions around the world for me that
moment was goku vs vegeta it was the
very first piece of material i ever saw
of dragon ball and because of the impact
that had on my life i've gone on to make
it my career and this fight sasuke vs
naruto this really and truly felt like
the culmination of the entire series
conveyed perfectly by kishimoto as the
strengths naruto has garnered across his
time spent with us are all used here to
full effect from his most bombastic and
ostentatious abilities like the shadow
clones and the rossen
all the way to the more subtle touches
like when he learned to walk on water
with jiraiya all of these skills are on
display here and used to full effect
serving to heighten the drama and make
this feel like we've reached a
significant endpoint what did catch me
off guard however was that a massive
portion of this fight is spent in
flashback a brilliant flashback but it
surprised me nevertheless the flashback
for sasuke while long added so much to
an occasion that felt as though it was
starved of sasuke's perspective we got
to see the decaying of sasuke's
relationship with his brother and the
origins of his entire purpose in life to
get revenge but one thing i will say
about this before i move on is that i
get the feeling that we're missing a
large part of this story namely itachi's
perspective on everything now it might
very well just turn out to be the case
that he's a cold-blooded murderer that
has no redeemable qualities but who
knows i'll see how that plays out in the
future concerning the fight itself the
action in the opening minutes felt
appropriately shocking and confusing due
to naruto's perspective however once the
flashback revealing sasuke's motivations
and full backstory concluded the fight
suddenly felt both appropriate for each
respective character and most
importantly perfectly focused the
paneling and layout work by kishimoto as
i mentioned earlier with the gara and
rockley encounter is some of the best in
the series with kishimoto really
demonstrating how far he's come as an
artist going from strength to strength
leading to naruto charging up his
rasengan and sasuke his chidori with the
paneling accompanying this being
stronger than anywhere else i've seen in
the manga there's a point of view shot
from underwater as we look on as these
two ninjas dance on the water's surface
with their weapons floating down to the
dark depths beneath and that might be my
favorite page out of the entire conflict
here however if i want to take a step
back for a second and think about things
more abstractly it is my belief that the
flashback we get after this concerning
kakashi's origins holds a lot more
meaning behind it than might be evident
at first glance
in this flashback kakashi's team is
composed of three individuals himself a
young boy called obito uchia and a girl
called rin and from this reflection on
his early training days we can see why
perhaps he's taken a keen interest in
sasuke taking him under his wings
seeking to teach him the chidori
technique of that original group obito
was clearly the overly emotional
underachiever like naruto was in
sasuke's group while rin could be a very
convincing stand-in for sakura given
that sakura herself would begin studying
the same jutsu rin was however while
reading this material i couldn't help
but cast my mind back to the first arc
where naruto sasuke and sakura sat
before kakashi in that very scene sasuke
explained in no uncertain terms what his
goals were demonstrating his
single-minded approach in becoming a
ninja and over the course of that story
this focus has remained and with the
farther and farther he pursued that line
of thinking kakashi began getting more
and more interested and involved in
sasuke's life and i think there's a
reason for it he saw himself in sasuke
kakashi's flashback wherein we first see
him use the todori technique he does so
not taking into account how his actions
will affect his teammates single-minded
also in his goal he ends up failing in
that effort for the most part and later
in that same flashback rin gets
kidnapped obito wants to rescue her but
kakashi insists on completing the
mission instead thankfully the
comparatively weaker obito convinces
kakashi to save her too and from this
it's clear to see the similarities
kakashi sees in sasuke particularly
striking for kakashi given that he lost
a close friend in the process of that
mission it's a touching flashback
highlighting the origins of his eye but
for me it highlighted instead the birth
of who kakashi is today by the end of
that sequence the chidori becomes a
technique not exclusively of destruction
but one that instead represents
protection of his closest loved ones
which recontextualized every instance he
used that move in the series for me
however if we are to think about this
one layer deeper his teaching of this
technique to sasuke with his explicit
explanation of when to use this
technique it effectively acts as kakashi
handing sasuke a representation of one's
desire to protect what's most important
to him hoping that it will become that
for him to help him see what's actually
important to focus on what you have
right now instead of what you lost and
so when the story climaxes in the
emphatic and grand fashion it does
naruto's resengan explodes on contact
with sasuke's chidori to create a
stunning inferno of a spectacle no doubt
but it's also a collision of two
techniques that offer snapshots of how
far one has come and how far astray the
other has fallen the act and display of
these techniques alone perfectly tell
the story of these two fierce characters
in a very real and metaphorical sense
with the technique that was designed to
protect those close to you very
literally being used in this instance to
tear down the one closest to sasuke
this arc wears many different masks it's
a character-driven drama it's a comedy
it's action and it's a thriller but in
the end this has become a story about
two characters more than anything else
and in the end
naruto's first part ends in tragedy
or does it the choice sasuke made to not
kill naruto says more about his
character than this entire fight ever
could and it's rather fitting that a
technique like chidori couldn't be used
to end the life of his friend overall my
impressions of this arc and read this
first section of naruto is a wonderful
one while it didn't start strong like
many other series do kishimoto and by
extension this story has a passion
behind it that much like its titular
character grew and grew more effective
with each subsequent arc i've
transformed from someone that didn't
know the first thing about naruto and
now i consider myself a massive fan of
kishimoto and the work he's produced
here with this section of the story the
arc was a massive finale befitting of
the occasion that managed to also feel
intimate at the same time i can't wait
to see where the story goes from here
and i honestly hope you guys will join
me for the ride
but before we wrap things up i want to
quickly plug a really cool podcast i was
on amazon prime video has put together
an anime podcast called animate to z
hosted by rapper shay lingo and comedian
beck hill they had me on to review the
vinlen saga anime so if you're
interested in my thoughts on that show
my episode will be out tomorrow as of
this video's upload i'll drop a link in
the description for anyone who wants to
check it out subscribe if you want to
see more when i start reading shippuden
next week but until then i've been told
not mark and thank you so much for
watching
[Music]